bonjour claude aujourd'hui un terrain
non julie je voudrais un grand vers des
sites rhône at il le fait à oui mais
alors si j'arrive à trouver la bouteille
parce que j'ai mis de l'ordre ce matin
et je me retrouve plus du tout du tout
est
ok merci verser 60 centimes 60 centimes
en baisse encore augmenté mais si tu
crois que c'est moi qui augmente pour le
plaisir tu te trouves tu n'as pas lu
dans les journaux ce qui s'est passé à
la dernière réunion des pays producteurs
des citrouilles bonté mais pas en colère
je sais bien que tu n'es pas responsable
a compté les impôts
d'accord les taxes nous enfin julie je
te faisais faire aucun reproche t c est
bien vrai mais oui je le promets à l'est
soit plus fâché va aller à les définir
la débat d'idées tout ton histoire m'a
donné faim mais j'ai envie de manger
quelque chose de très beau tu vas manger
du chocolat non des bombes aussi trop à
l'amour alors en jeu j'ai envie de
quelque chose de très très très bon il
ne tarde tottenham ou bien ou bien un
millefeuille tu me donnes far west mais
moi si c'était moi qui choisis ça je
prendrai une grosse priant sans oublier
des éclairs au chocolat et une meringue
à la crème chantilly ça vous plairait un
bon goûter comme ça oui et bosser il en
cuisine je n'avais pas entendu arriver
non j'étais ému je voudrais vous
demander une faveur mais arts et
plaisirs vas-y voilà je voudrais vous
inviter à un très bon goûter oui et qui
va le préparer moi mail à toi même ouais
et alors et bien non juste une question
comme ça
bompard alors vous êtes d'accord da
c'est à dire que oui la libye ont tous
accepté avec joie avec joie bon alors je
me dépêche jb la roja je suis content de
vous inviter à les raconter vraiment pas
chaud tu d'avoir eu l'air d'hésiter au
bout tu es drôle pas non non mais tu
t'imagines en train de manger une une
glace aux anchois ou ou un gloubi boulga
avec de la saucisse et du chocolat est
encore une meringue chantilly avec de la
moutarde ou là là là là c'est vrai
j'avais oublié oui d'autant plus que moi
j'ai préparation et mme aussi et si on
mange que kazinian nous apporte on est
sûr d'être tous malades alors qu'est ce
qu'on va faire écoute j'ai dû pas ici et
si on mange ça avec du chocolat comme ça
on n'aura plus fin et on pourra faire
semblant de toucher à très très bonne
idée
claudine uriel voulez du pain et du
chocolat vous préférez attendre le
retour de cassini ray manger ce qu'il a
apporté
et vous olivier frédéric et les autres
du pain et du chocolat ou le goûter de
casimir
le bouter de comme vous voulez je crois
qu'à moi attend au g 20
lecteurs
on confond rebelles sont revenus un
petit peu parce que non il était
l'imam al amam
voilà
et voilà c'est price et chocolat pas ce
chocolat était vraiment très bon mais je
crois que j'ai trop manger bon moi aussi
je serai capable d'avaler quoi que ce
soit d'autre bon ben voilà
julie françois muriel claude tous les
enfants venez vite le goûter ont servi à
nosy julie du courage
nous nous voici casimir a dit tu nous as
rien préparé c'est une surprise tout est
dans la malle magique à c'est encore
plus inquiétant que je ne pensais
attention
aux abois
alors il y a des tartes aux pommes des
éclairs d'escudé millefeuille mr des
brioches des meringues la seiche
antilles et
tout ce dont nous avions il y
aurait deux patchs casimir nous avons
douté de toi nous sommes bien punis nous
sommes vraiment des idiots
enfants vont justement cela va très mal
il a l'estomac vide mais c'est
impossible casimir avant-hier encore tu
avais une énorme réserve de gloubiboulga
tu n'a quand même pas tous terminé à toi
tout seul en si peu de temps
non mais hier soir mes neveux sont venus
guinée et vous avez tous manger ils ont
un appétit énorme casimir pourquoi ne
vas tu pas acheter un peu de chocolat
pour le rap et de la confiture de
fraises quelques bananes bien mûrs pour
les écraser de la moutarde de dijon et
de la saucisse de toulouse cru mais
tiède chez les messieurs l'île aux
enfants
décidément en soit une audi corps des
bêtises on a vraiment casimir tu es trop
susceptible je ne vois pas ce que j'ai
dit comme bêtises ah mais c'est toi
qu'il trouve susceptibles à moi histoire
d'enfin au maire françois cazis mire
vous n'allez quand même pas vous
disputez le sont nos ennemis tu as un
génie bonjour je suis bien content que
vous soyez là vous vous êtes témoin
françois s'est emporté bêtement quoi
parfaitement
il a prétendu que je ne disais que des
bêtises ouais et alors quoi pourquoi
mais parce que tu devrais savoir qu'il
est impossible d'aller acheter ce que tu
me demandes pour la bonne et simple
raison que c'est aujourd'hui comme
monsieur pommiers les piscines d'eau
lille marie sa fille dominique a ou non
mais c'est vrai j'en avais complètement
oublié il a raison nous lui avons même
envoyé des fleurs casimir je demande
pardon nos vieux tu as dit vrai je ne
dis que dd c'est pas grave je t'en
reparle nero jours tout le monde
bonjour la misère à kasubi un pur sur
cette urgence c'est un taquet recommandé
tiens moi mais d'abord signent quasiment
ici tu vas t'en des attaques et casimir
ah oui j'avais tellement faim j'ai
envoyé un télégramme à ma tante adélaïde
pas si ce sont des victuailles le paquet
n'est pas un groupe au nom alors il est
pas lourd vous savez un
tien kazemi a pu oublier au yen l'être
aussi casimir
voilà et bien mes amis moi il faut que
je continue ma tournée alors on voit à
bientôt à bientôt en valeur
abbas c'est bien ma tante adélaïde très
bien et tu es que dit elle mais enfin
cela ne vous regarde pas ce paquet est
pour moi au casimir soit chanté l'hymne
ou la lettre de ta tante adélaïde
non tu ne veux pas que je trouve ton
petit paquet mais nous on
jette un mois ce sont des champignons
des champignons
tu sais que les champignons à la grecque
c'est très beau
moi je sais préparer une recette
d'omelette aux champignons qui tachent
les noms des 10 sport mais ma tante
adélaïde m'envoyer ces champignons rien
que pour moi
tu sais casimir je ne doute pas du
savoir de ta tante adélaïde mais les
champignons s'il les a ramassés
elle-même
[Musique]
oui j'espère qu'elle sait reconnaître
les bons des mauvais
parce qu'il ya des champignons qui sont
très dangereux
j'ai entendu dire qu'un seul dans le tas
un seul pouvait rompois zone et tous les
autres vous croyez
casimir je te conseille de nous montrer
ce champignon non mais pourquoi
parce que s'ils sont tous bons vous
allez vouloir vivre et manger avec moi
oui vie demandait s'ils sont tous
mauvais et que tu n'as pas de lait du
lait pourquoi du lait oui si tu t'en
foisonnent il faut boire du lait c'est
un contrepoison j'en ai un litre dans le
kiosque d'ailleurs
c'est tout ce qu'il faut si c'est pas
trop grave ou et oui parce que si c'est
très grave il faut un lavage d'estomac
et comment reconnectera bons champignons
d'un mauvais et bien les gens qui s'y
connaissent ça devait reconnaître mais
il ya tellement d'espèces de shopping
si on s'y connaît pas vraiment il faut
mieux pas y toucher du tout
[Musique]
bon et bien écoutez
je vous raconterai la forme le goût et
la couleur qu'ils ont quand je les aurai
manger
casimir fait quand même très attention
tu sais que nous t'aimons beaucoup
casimir
merci mes amis pour gars
bien l'omelette aux champignons ce sera
pour une autre fois et oui
ajouté bien bien au bac
à légumes des champignons ce moment là
j'étais chaud ce mauvais
manger j'avais tellement faim on ce qu
il comptait les champignons passe moi
c'est
will all hallow's eve
ou amex il vouloir faire du bien la doit
voilà
merci mes amis a présenté à venir je
viens avec nous à l'hôpital c'est faire
un lavage d'estomac
chasser la peur c'est timide soit pas un
homme avait fait de son mieux ce n'est
pas gros si tu fais une heure mais
françois n'est des champignons de paris
n'ont jamais fait de mal à personne et j
choi youn ou paris ouais il alors mais
alors casimir tu n'es pas empoisonner
menon enfin tu ne pensais quand même pas
que ma tante adélaïde aller
m'empoisonner mois son neveu préféré et
pourquoi tu du moule et alors eh bien je
savais soit ce que je n'avais plus rien
à boire alors j'ai pensé qu'un peu de
lait frais ça me ferait pas mal
et bien tant pis pour toi casimir
pourquoi
c'était justement train de te préparer
un superbe gâteau d'anchois et sans lait
je ne peux rien faire oh oh oh jolie
[Musique]